the Winter Olympics are taking place in
freezing cold temperatures but the
relationship between North and South
Korea appears to be thawing for the
first time the two countries feel that a
joint hockey team for the games players
from the north joined the South's
national team the sharing of the ice
isn't limited to nations however sisters
from one American family are both
competing but with an unusual twist Dana
Jacobson is in Pyeongchang South Korea
with their improbable story Dana good
morning good morning siblings competing
in the same Winter Olympics in the same
sport is nothing new but siblings doing
that for two different countries is rare
in fact it's only happened a handful of
times at this Winter Olympics that's
exactly what Hannah and Marissa brandt
are doing sharing their unique version
of the olympic dream we're so close in
age so everything we did we did together
whether it was sports or Korean culture
camp you know we were in it all together
so it was great having her marissa and
hannah brandt have teamed up all their
lives but in Pyeongchang the sisters are
taking the ice for two different teams
Hannah for Team USA my mom told me that
at one point I'd watched one of the
Olympics and I was like mom I want to be
out there one day and I was like what do
I have to do like how do they find me
Marissa
for the unified Korean team getting the
call to go to Korea it was just
something I couldn't say no to I found
myself saying yes right away and that
and the opportunity to be in the
Olympics just happened and I really
can't believe we are here now being able
to represent my birth country it's just
amazing it's just something I never
could have dreamed of born in South
Korea Marisa was just four months old
when she was adopted by Greg and Robin
brand her new home 6,000 miles away in a
picturesque suburb of st. Paul Minnesota
younger sister Hannah is one of
America's best young hockey talents on a
US roster packed full of expectation
it's a dream come true to be there and
to be there with my sister too and just
I want to enjoy every second of it and
while Hannah and Marissa are now
competitors on the ice that wasn't
always the case we were able to play on
the same team pretty much every year
growing up and just spent a lot of extra
time together
we might not normally have been able to
sounds like you guys created an
incredible bond with that yeah
definitely I think hockey brought us
closer together connected by their love
of the game that bond lasted while each
played college hockey for different
schools now for different countries both
sisters get to play in the Olympics what
does that mean it's kind of like fate
for it to have worked out the way it has
I don't think either of us could have
ever dreamed of it I think for my
parents who it's just they're just so
proud of both of us and excited for the
journey that's ahead what is it like
knowing you have two daughters going to
the Olympics it's gonna be it's gonna be
busy because we have a game every day I
don't think we ever imagined it can you
explain the pride you must feel you know
one for the u.s. I mean that's you know
you're just so prideful in that and then
and then Marissa representing the
country of Korea and at her birth
country just unbelievable and for both
of you
it's a chance to go to a country that
brought you your daughter well we had
always hoped we'd be able to go as a
family but with all hockey and
everything we've done just never
happened that we got to go together so
it's really special to get to go over
now and you know go to the Olympics and
see where Marissa came from and we're
gonna spend some time with her and she's
gonna show us around and so it's really
unbelievable Marissa says spending time
here in South Korea while training for
the Olympics has helped her embrace both
the country and its culture that she's
become more accepting of herself and her
roots your name for your Jersey what is
your Jersey say it will say yunjeong
which is my Korean name that my birth
mother gave me I think that name isn't
very common in Korea
maybe my birth mom will come forward and
maybe read my story and kind of put two
and two together and maybe say something
if you could say something to your birth
mother
what would you say um it's gonna make me
cry
maybe that I'm just thankful that she
put me up for adoption and kind of
wanted better light for me um there's
something I'm thankful for yeah just
thankful the girl up here and have the
parents that I do this though yeah not
to mention her sister Hannah if there
was a Brant sisters goal what would that
be at the Olympics
yeah I guess just to enjoy every second
of it embrace all the little moments
that happen at the Olympics I think it
would be fun to play each other you know
it's it's not impossible but a lot would
have to happen to do that but I think
just for us it's just to have fun
represent your country well they're not
many women Korean hockey players so for
me just to be a role model to them and
I'm sure that's the same with my sister
just to be a role model and hopefully
have young ones look up to you and just
see that hockey's fun and a lot would
actually have to happen for Hannah
Marisa to face off it would only happen
in the gold medal round in South Korea
is a very long shot for that but the
sister connection is going strong here
in Pyeongchang the US team actually has
a set of twins on it and the Swiss team
has two sets of sisters John Jacobs in
Pyeongchang thanks oh what a story
young John I hope that her mother sees
her and what incredible athletes they
are it has brought chills to me about
sisters and amazing parents